so when i got the ransomware um when i
got uh with the zero day attacked on the
qnap nas
you know
they they basically say the the
criminal is qnap the company
for having so many security
vulnerabilities
they're
uh like you are the victim of qnap's
incompetence that's the way they kind of
phrase it and see i don't agree with
that
i don't agree with that at all
so
solarwinds
[Laughter]
let's so i've got 130 page class action
lawsuit printed out at the house i've
been going through it that catalogs how
solar winds lied for years about their
vulnerabilities and they lied to
investors the the people who came in the
auditors who would co who they would
hire would you know they would
not pay attention to them when they said
you know you've got these issues they
would say go away
[ __ ] like that for years until
solarwinds you know the attacks become
apparent um
my view on that is that the only person
responsible for the crime
are the criminals who did the attacking
the actual criminals not not solar with
now does that mean the solar winds isn't
isn't all [ __ ] up they are and there
needs to be some accounting in place
but the the the only individual the only
people responsible for crime
are the criminals and that's either
online in the physical world what have
you could be it's
being an idiot
is not a crime
you know being being
being criminally negligent is yeah and i
think that that solarwinds is certainly
responsible
not not responsible they're culpable
for what happened can you actually uh
tell folks about solarwinds what is it
um
what what was what are some interesting
things that you're aware of solarwinds
was very it was
it provided a background a backbone of
security for
hundreds thousands of different
companies um
if you looked at a lot of security
companies were using solarwinds that
would that would allow you to get a
snapshot of the entire system
that they were working on so what
happens is is you get a russian group
that comes in
and they
basically they hack into solarwinds and
get access to it and it allows them to
view every single thing
i mean every single thing
about every single client
that
solarwinds had at that point so entire
snapshots of all the iep that weren't
that was going on all the emails all the
communications every single secret that
was going on with those companies if
company had software like microsoft it
allowed them to look at the source code
of everything that was going on i mean
it's just a complete and total nightmare
all right and something that you are not
going to recover from
you're not
i mean it's done at that point um
you know there's not been a lot of news
lately about it but the fact of the
matter is is that's the type of attack
that's a catastrophic attack so there's
a huge amount of information
that was read
saved elsewhere probably oh yeah and so
now there's people sitting on
information absolutely so think about
one of the attack vectors has been
microsoft outlook 365 things like that
this allowed the attackers to look at
the source codes of that
so they have the source code now so they
go through it line by line
what are the vulnerabilities let's find
new vulnerabilities new zero days you
know i said zero days aren't common but
this opens up an entire new threat
surface all of a sudden so it's a it's a
completely catastrophic attack once all
the chips are down everything's tallied
up people are gonna be like yeah we're
done we're done
all right this whole computer thing
we're trying we're done we're walking
away wait what's that
that's terrifying because so you're
saying that there's not been
obvious uh big negative impact from that
yet so but like there's been a lot of
negative impact but we're just starting
right so they're starting the capacity
for destruction is huge here how much
involvement from nation states do you
think there is
on this you know it's interesting um
so you've got iran you've got uh north
korea china russia you've got the big
four you've also got brazil
you've got all these other countries
that are interested in the united states
as well um
nation states are interesting depending
on who the nation state is
all right so russia is very good about
working with the type of criminal i used
to be you know they'll enlist these guys
and steal information what have you then
russia will take the information they
want to and they'll basically go off and
sell whatever you want to make some
money
china's all about ip
north korea is about stealing money
because they really don't know what what
the hell else to do right now
but
so north korea is actively involved in
cybercrime absolutely they've stolen a
shitload of bitcoin everything else
so absolutely they're actively involved
with that um
very very skilled attackers very skilled
but even if you look at you know i told
you that stat about 90
alright
so even though solar winds is going to
be
the number one attack
the the follow-up to that is this not
pedia attack that happened and so that
was the most sophisticated attack
launched by the russian sand worm group
using all known exploits throughout so
it's not again it's not
you're right in the sophistication is
typically not technical sophistication
but it's that social engineering
sophistication how do you get these
things put together in line to attack
and succeed
but when you get access to the source
code that's where technical
sophistication could really do a lot of
damage and that's when you find out real
quick
that's what separates the men from the
boys in this game all right because all
of a sudden it's not i don't have to
worry about social engineering i've got
source codes and i've got professionals
that are looking at that
and that's your ass
you